hi i'm lauren from khan academy and
today i'm going to give you an overview
of how to set up accounts for yourself
and your children on khan academy we'll
also go over how you can find relevant
content for your kids and view their
progress
this video is meant for parents with
kids who are 12 or under if your child
is 13 or older please see our other
video called parent quick start tips for
kids ages 13 plus
we will start by having your child
create an account on khan academy
creating an account lets you and your
child track progress and time spent
learning
go to www.khanacademy.org
and click sign up in the upper right
hand corner
on the sign up page
enter your child's date of birth
and click sign up by choosing a username
on the next page enter your email
address
and choose a username for your child
then click sign up
next
choose a starting point for your child's
learning journey
in the personalize khan academy pop-up
select your child's grade
and click
continue on the next page you'll see
courses that we recommend for your child
choose one or more and click continue
you can also click the see all link
to view the full menu
your child is ready to go have them
click the blue start button for any
course to start with the very first
lesson or click see all to browse the
entire course
if you're not sure what level your child
is at here's a tip
most khan academy math courses include a
course challenge that can help you
quickly find where your child needs
practice and where they're already good
to go
to get there scroll to the bottom of the
course page and click start course
challenge
these usually take 30 to 45 minutes and
will give you some good clues about
where to direct their learning you can
have your child start one grade level
below their current grade or even start
at kindergarten and work their way up
next let's create a parent account you
must create a parent account within
seven days or all child accounts will be
deleted to create an account check your
email for each child you'll have an
approve your child's khan academy
account email waiting
click the green allow my child to use
khan academy button
check your updates or other mail folders
if you don't see this email right away
follow the prompts to sign up for a new
account or sign into an existing account
using the email address where you
receive the email
once you sign up you'll be taken to your
parent dashboard if you want to view
your child's progress you can click on
your child's username
this takes you to the progress report
where you can keep track of what they're
learning and how much time they're
spending
your child can also see this report
through their account by clicking
progress in their left navigation
thanks for watching and we hope you and
your child enjoy learning on khan
academy